[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN COATES: Lawyers and negotiate
deals and manage lawsuits involving
billions of dollars each year.
To do that, they need more
than purely legal expertise.
KENNETH FEINBERG: If
you don't know numbers
and you can't deal with concepts like
economic loss and likelihood of income
in the future, you'll find yourself
sort of at sea without a compass.
JOHN COATES: You need a fundamental
understanding of finance,
how to read financial
statements, how to analyze them,
and how to use financial concepts
to value a business, or a patent,
or a marital estate.
You need more than law to help a
client even decide whether to sue.
BALA DHARAN: Lawyers cannot
leave accounting, finance,
and valuation to a finance
team or outside experts.
Through examples of valuation
disputes and presentations
from real-world
practitioners, this course
will teach you how to interpret
and use financial data,
make a business case
for a deal or a lawsuit,
and know when and how experts can
support or undermine your work.
JOHN COATES: Based on an essential
course at Harvard Law School,
this course is one of the few available
at the intersection of law and finance.
PATRICIA LAUCELLA: A lot of lawyers
are not real strong in numbers.
So if you can do both, I
think you have an advantage
over some of your colleagues.
JOHN COATES: Walk in
the footsteps of experts
to learn how they use judgment to
answer difficult questions from both
a financial and a legal perspective.
[MUSIC PLAYING]